Estados Unidos seguirá operando en Irak
es lo que anunció el Secretario de
Defensa de Estados Unidos
Austin en una visita sorpresa a Bagdad
Este martes aunque esta vez fueron
invitados por el gobierno iraquí
ahora nuestra cooperación en materia de
defensa contra Dash es un Pilar clave de
nuestra relación bilateral y Estados
Unidos sigue comprometido con esta lucha
en apoyo a la seguridad de Irak y de
toda la región la nación norteamericana
tiene actualmente
2.500 soldados desplegados en Irak para
asesorar al país en la lucha contra el
estado islámico
las fuerzas estadounidenses están
dispuestas a permanecer en Irak por
invitación el gobierno de Irak ahora
estas fuerzas están operando en un papel
de no combate asesoramiento asistencia y
habilitación Para apoyar la lucha contra
el terrorismo liderada por Irak
esta declaración llega a unos días del
vigésimo aniversario de la invasión de
Irak por Estados Unidos
el 20 de marzo de 2003 las fuerzas
estadounidenses invadieron Irak
afirmando que el presidente Sadam tenía
armas de destrucción masiva algo que fue
reconocido como falso meses después un
ataque cuya legalidad ha sido
cuestionada la guerra provocó la muerte
de decenas de miles de civiles iraquíes
y creó una inestabilidad que participó
en el ascenso de los militantes del
estado islámico en 2011 el mismo loyd
Austin anunció que Estados Unidos había
alcanzado sus objetivos militares en
Irak y las tropas estadounidenses se
fueron del país pero en 2014 frente a la
toma de varias ciudades importantes por
parte del estado islámico Barack Obama
envió de nuevo centenas de soldados al
territorio a pesar de declarar la
victoria de ira K sobre los terroristas
en 2017 hoy en día el grupo yihadista
Aunque debilitado sigue actuando en el
país